A text becomes unclear when you use too many words or if you use complicated words in a business report.
Wanting to impress the reader or thinking that we ought to write in this way is often the reason.
But the fact is that it is difficult for people to follow the meaning of a complex and flowery text.
Therefore, misunderstandings occur and time is wasted.
Writing should express, not impress.
The more technical and difficult the matter is, the simpler the writing should be.
Sentences should be short, and too many words of 3 or 4 syllables should be avoided.
Use 15 to 25 words per sentence.
One more important thing is that emoticons commonly used in Korea...
...like T T or 2 carets are considered cute in Asia, but considered unprofessional in the Western business world.
They are used in private emails and on chat lines.